The people at the Expo love Grant's product, his glasses wipers. But they find
that washing their glasses with water just isn't enough. There needs to be some
sort of cleaning solution that will be the solution to their problem. Grant
decides to get on it right away. He contacts the three biggest lens cleaning
solution vendors and asks them how much they charge to buy their solution in
bulk. He needs this stuff fast. So, he asks how much it would be to get these
samples rush ordered. Grant takes careful notes when he's on the phone with
these companies. Once he's done, he has the following information. Brand number
1 charges $10 per gallon of solution plus a $100 rush order fee. The second
brand charges $8 a gallon plus a $200 rush order fee. And the third brand
charges $10 per gallon with a $150 rush order fee. Now, Grant has some decisions
to make. He needs to figure out how much solution he needs to buy and who he
should buy it from.